sources tell CBS News Osama bin Laden's
favorite son has been killed in a
military operation
Hamza bin Laden was in line to take over
al-qaeda the terror group founded by his
father David Martin is at the Pentagon
David good morning good morning the
facts surrounding the operation which
killed Homs have bin Laden remained
murky it is not yet clear when or where
it happened although he was thought to
be operating somewhere along the border
between Afghanistan and Pakistan
officials say US intelligence recently
monitored conversations among members of
al-qaeda debating whether or not to keep
humps as death a secret or acknowledge
it and celebrate him as a martyr based
on that intelligence US officials
believe Hamza was killed in a strike
even though he was not the target
with his father's name and charisma
hamza represented the future of al-qaeda
even though Ayman al-zawahri bin Laden's
longtime deputy has led al-qaeda since
the 2011 raid which killed its leader
the United States has conducted an
operation that killed Osama bin Laden
the leader of al-qaeda letters captured
in the 2011 raid indicated bin Laden was
grooming hamsa to be the next leader
the wajarri didn't measure up to bin
Laden and they suffered from that and
the loss of hamza i think is pretty
substantial because there's not another
hamza behind him Fran Townsend was
president george w bush's
counterterrorism adviser you take out
somebody like that at the top of an
organization and an organization is
going to flounder for leadership as
recently as last february the u.s.
believed hamza was alive and offered a 1
million dollar reward for information
leading to his capture or death al Qaeda
tried to protect Thomas's identity by
not releasing pictures of him as an
adult this video of his wedding was
released by the CIA after it was
captured in the raid which killed his
father President Trump
brushed aside questions about Hamza
skilling Wednesday
without hamza al qaeda is an ageing
organization a recent pentagon report
said it poses a very limited threat to
the u.s. in afghanistan which of course
was once the base for the 9/11 attacks
Anthony David Martin thank you David